this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you Dave so yeah I'm
glad that Lynde I presented a few of the
details about the partial budget
analysis because I'm gonna follow up on
that a little bit that's what this
survey was in part about so quick
background story is that I started
working with Dave within New York State
soil health initiative last fall and
they've had this idea to expand upon the
idea of these use case studies and look
at a little bit of a broader picture of
the costs and the benefits that farmers
were experiencing across the state and
try to capture many different types of
cropping systems so Dave and I came up
with this questionnaire that we
distributed so farmers across the state
during the fall in the winter of last
year and overall we collected 182
responses covering almost all the
companies in New York and we broke those
down into when we asked farmers to
report the types of crops that they grew
some of the practices that they used
especially focusing on cover crops
reduced tillage and soil amendments
which included organic matter like newer
compost mulch woodchips things like that
so we got a pretty pretty good
representation across the state
especially capturing some of these more
active agricultural districts let's see
here in this slide and then one of the
more interesting things right up front
that came out of this was that we asked
first indicate some of the major
constraints that they we're seeing on
their farm and the top three that rose
to the top here were poor drainage soil
compaction and soil erosion and all
three of these are really problems that
can be addressed with reduced tillage
cover crops and bring em in amendments
um so this is a this slide is a
simplified version of the table that you
might see on the handout that you have
and what we did here is we asked first
when testify the pot or in this one on
the benefits of reduced village that
they were seeing and again going back to
Lynn's talk these could be increases in
income or reductions in expenses and
what really Kim is up here is for
reduced tillage less labour was a big
one
and another aspect of of this this
result here is that we separated out
farmers who were using reduced tillage
on exclusively vegetable crops and
exclusively corn and soy and we were
interested in in looking at those those
two groups and seeing if they were
seeing different benefits and indeed
there were there were a few differences
this next slide is a super illustration
of those differences you can see the
vegetables and the green there and the
corns play is yellow this is this is
showing that vegetable growers reported
that they're seeing greater yields from
the reduced tillage practices as a
higher rate than the quantity growers
and then of course in the left there you
can see overall rate at which producers
were in greater yields which is
significant so it's about 50% there
and we also looked the the difference of
crops again we separated that out
according the strugglers and the
vegetable growers here those two groups
and again we see that they have
different they're experiencing different
benefits and also it's don't really
noticeable that erosion the erosion
control benefit of the cover crops is
really noticeable over 95% of instantly
growers are reporting that that's really
number one for the cover crops and then
more illustrations here these the
differences between the two crop groups
again we see that the vegetable growers
then are the green there and they're
reporting almost an 80% rate greater
cash crop yields and they're using their
cover crops but we're not really seeing
that benefit quite as much in the corn
so many however once my growers do see
other benefits here we see that they're
sort of combining cover crops within our
last operations and I'm using those
cover crops as animal force and that's
if they're seeing but didn't visible
growers tend to have less integration I
think with with livestock and so they're
not seeing those benefits
and so David David Montgomery especially
just talked about how farmers can use
these practices to organic matter
over some minatom and that's that's
really important is trying to figure out
how long some of those changes might
take
so we these farmers that completed the
survey today on told us basically how
long they've been doing these practices
and we grouped them by their experience
level one to five years five to ten
years ten to twenty and twenty plus
years and what we saw were some pretty
interesting evidence that emerged from
this this slide is showing a percentage
of each group at practices reduced
tillage on the percentage of each group
reporting less erosion and we can see
here pretty clearly as time goes on on
your x-axis there you're pushing to make
plus years and the percent of farmers
reporting less erosion is almost at 100%
whereas if we start down here and we
look at the one to five years
twenty-five percent there so um two
things maybe to note here is that you do
see some benefits right away but don't
likelihood that you're going to see
those benefits increase over time is
evident and we use the chi-square test
there to show that that's a significant
association sinking here this is also a
really interesting result not necessary
necessarily related to sort of health
but we're seeing that more experienced
farmers who've been doing reduced
tillage in longer they're taking a
better advantage of these posture
programs so this could be a way to an
area of improvement in terms of policy
maybe outreach
trying to get some of these these
farmers who are getting started training
fit them enrolled in some of these some
of these programs
and finally we're seeing often yields at
about 10 years so once once these
farmers have been using cover crops for
10 years the percentage of them that
report greater yields has really jumping
up so I think that's a little bit of an
indication that it takes time for these
practices to fully fully benefit the
farmer and the producer but finally we
looked at the ability of these different
practices to provide resilience to
extreme weather events
I missed the future climate is unknown
but it's anticipated that a severe
severe rainfall may become more frequent
and stood out as possibilities on both
cover crops can reduce tillage in
improve your soil spill organic matter
and that can theoretically improve your
resilience to some of these extreme
weather events but we kind of wanted to
test this hypothesis and again this is
you know this is the results of 182
farmers using these practices and we're
seeing
the best performances from cover crops I
would say overall but there could be
some wiggle room there but I guess
that's the takeaway here is that book
cover crops and reduced tillage are
providing resilience to to help farmers
make it through droughts helping them
create soils that retain their water
better and also helping prevent erosion
that might happen when they experience a
heavy rainfall
so I
guess I could take a couple questions
and I guess I'd like that
also add that there is this handout in
the packet though if we're gonna be
writing up and publishing some future
papers and stuff like that so keep an
eye out for it
any questions I can't really say that
that's I can't really say that that's
that that's a real difference I think so
these bars are gonna have a certain
degree of uncertainty on this it's not
money that's exactly what the rate is
going to be stuff there's a little bit
of wiggle room there on the important
thing to look at is the chi-square
p-value so that's showing that there is
an association between the length of
time that the farmers been doing the
practice and the likelihood that they
responded they they were getting greater
yields
so again I mean this is also a very
complicated system that we're looking at
so there could be you know there could
be other things that come into play
there I can't really say for sure but
but we do know that there's there's a
pattern here
anybody else yep go ahead I would say
yeah I mean there's there's definitely
some other things going on here like we
also found that there was a little bit
of a tendency for some of these farmers
that have been doing the practices
longer or growing certain crops and not
others so to really get to the bottom of
this I think we'd have to do some kinda
more involved modeling that would really
tease out how all these factors affect
yields for example
and it's your question
ray it's it was it was how basically how
long have you been using this practice
so it could you know there could be it
could be something like that maybe older
farmers used slightly different
practices and that right right right
yeah it was it was about the perception
of of the result
um we didn't express explicitly ask that
I I would imagine it would be both we
didn't we didn't really discriminate and
again it was it was farms of all sizes
all crop types and yeah I suggest you
look for one of the publications or my
contact information is on there if you
want to get in touch with us and we can
send you some more information
actually one in one interesting thing
that I just remembered was that there
was one farmer who wrote in a response
that basically indicated that the rent
that they paid to the landowner somehow
went down maybe they've had some sort of
you know they negotiated or whatever but
um that was that was an interesting
thing that somebody just wrote in thank
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu